Good afternoon everyone.
So very happy to be here. Going to
hopefully give you my
background like a some just even just
the language like a framework to think
about
uh
problems why actually we need all these
geometric notions that we're going to
spend all these lectures talking about
and how do these geometric notions fit
into the bigger picture of learning
stuff learning functions in high
dimensions. And so as as it was as
happened last year
the the aim here is to be to go very
slow and please if you as soon as you
have any question do not hesitate to to
interrupt me. All right? So today we are
going to the lecture is going to be
split roughly into kind of three
chapters or like three sections. First
we're going to really go very slowly
introducing the basic elements of
statistical learning. So what are the
main mathematical object that we need to
think about the problem of fitting data
like
basically fitting trying to extract
information from data.
Then we are going to spend we're going
to discuss
about the curse of dimensionality which
is a phenomena that is kind of pervasive
and it's
underlying all the
things that are happening in deep
learning. And then we are going to in
the third part of the last part of the
lecture we are going to see how we can
address this curse of dimensionality
precisely with the ideas that are
specific to this geometric learning
course. All right?
Okay so let's get started.
So
if I wanted to just give you the the
basic object the basic elements of
statistical learning in one slide this
is how I would do it. Right? So so for
me
what we are going to focus is mostly
like four main objects that are going to
be interacting with each other. The
first one is data. Right? So the way we
think about data is using a kind of a
statistical formalism. Right? So we
think about data as being samples from a
probability distribution. Okay so this
probability distribution in the case of
supervised learning has two components
has the input which might be let's say
the image like this.
You see here.
Or it could be you know like a sequence
of text and also some labels.
Then we are going to mix this data
distribution with a model with an
approximation model that is the the
class of functions that are
parameterized by our parameters
that are hopefully trying to fit the
input to the output. Right? This is the
approximation model.
Then we are going to
combine like we're going to try to fit
the parameters of this model using an
error metric like some kind of loss
function
using an algorithm. The estimation
algorithm. Right? So these are the the
four pieces that kind of constitutes the
the basics of a statistical learning.
All right. So the data.
So again we are going to think about the
data we are going to define just in
terms of notation
think about the the data in the context
of supervised learning as having two
components. Right? So XI is going always
going to denote the input and YI is
going to denote the label.
And so here what we see is that we we
are going to assume or we are going to
postulate that the samples that the
input images are drawn from a data
distribution that we call new.
Okay? And this data distribution is a
probability distribution defined over
the input space
that we call capital X.
Okay so capital X from now on
corresponds to the input space of the
algorithm of the machine learning
algorithm.
Okay and here there's a picture that I
borrowed from some of my colleagues of
trying to illustrate right that these
are kind of the samples that are drawn
from from whatever from the space of
images. Okay and then uh
for starters for
trying to simplify a little bit the the
exposition here we are going to assume
that we have labels that have no noise.
Right? So YI can be obtained can be
produced by some unknown function F
star. Right? So F star the goal of the
game is to estimate this unknown
function F star. Right? That is mapping
the input to the to the
the input to the output. Right? And just
some examples
um
you can think about F star of X as some
you know some excitation energy of a
molecule or some you know chemical
property of some biological compound
like some molecular or protein whatever.
Or if you think about problems in
classification this could be
F of X could be the probability that you
know the image X
contains a cat.
Right? That could be a an example of a
of a function F star that you would like
to estimate.
Right?
Um
So obviously
if I want to we want to analyze
algorithms and try to reason about why
this architecture works better than the
other or why this algorithm work better
than this other algorithm we need to
have some assumptions. Right? There's a
there's this important kind of folkloric
folkloric result that there's no free
lunch. Right? In in in in this problem
right if I have no assumptions on the
data or no assumptions on the target
function there's no way I can guarantee
that my algorithm is going to work.
Okay so
really all all is all this course is
really about
what kind of assumptions are realistic
or reasonable for the problems that we
care about.
Okay.
So now we can we can discuss about the
model like the the the the parametric
class like the you know it's the choice
of the user where we are going to
essentially consider a subset of
functions that we call capital F.
So these are functions
that each function is like a small F
that maps the input space
to the output space. Here by again by
simplicity we just assume that the
output of the function is scalar. Right?
Maybe it's just a logit or some energy.
Right?
Obviously if you if you think about like
the output of your problem to be you
know like like
like the probability over 100 classes
you can replace the R by like the
corresponding vector in probability that
corresponds to the output space.
Okay and again some examples of this
hypothesis class
could be well maybe I could just try to
fit the data
with um
polynomials. Okay so I could just
consider that I want to I want to try to
learn the input to the output by
polynomials of maybe fixing the degree.
Maybe two three you know K could be
anything. Or I could also
try to use
try to use as a model a neural networks
where
with given architecture. Okay? That's
obviously the example that is going to
be mostly the focus of this class.
Okay. And so there's one
element one
object new object here that is very
important from a theoretical perspective
and it's also somehow hidden sometimes
it's hidden in the algorithmic sense
which is the complexity. Okay? So what
is the complexity measure?
So think think about the complexity
measure as a way to organize different
hypothesis. Right? So here for example
in the example above I told you that
there's my my function class contains
polynomials up to degree K.
So maybe you agree with me that within
this class there's easy polynomials and
hard polynomials. Maybe the polynomials
of degree one are you know less complex
than polynomials of degree two and
polynomials of degree two are less
complex than polynomials of degree three
and so on and so forth.
So more generally you can think that for
every element in your family
I can I can assign a notion of
complexity.
Okay? What they call this gamma.
And this is something that we are going
to use later on to argue and to think
about
basically statistical learning. Right?
So and just an example of again of how
what this complexity would look like in
practice for us maybe you can think
about the complexity as being the number
of neurons or the number of parameters
in a neural network.
This is not it's a good it's a intuitive
example but it's not always the right
thing. Right? But but just to to
illustrate the point. We can also think
about the notions of complexity that are
applied in broader classes. These are
kind of non-parametric classes like
Sobolev like you know general functions
that have a little little bit of
smoothness. So there's actually a notion
of complexity that measures the
smoothness of a hypothesis. Right? So if
I have a function a hypothesis that you
know that it looks like for example if
this is the
so this is the input
and this is the output.
Well maybe this function here over here
is going to be less complex than this
function over here. Right? Maybe.
Okay so so obviously that this is a
less complex
and this is more complex.
So in this particular example we can
measure we can quantify this smoothness
complexity with smoothness. Right? And
this no this quantity if you are if you
have ever seen Sobolev spaces is
measuring kind of the
how large is the second derivative of
the function.
There's one thing also that I want to
measure that I want to mention here.
Right? It's an important remark um
that um
is in particular relevant for those of
you who are already been practicing and
you know interacting with neural
networks is that often this notion of
complexity is hidden. Right? In the
algorithm. It's not something that we
can
that we explicitly manipulate. Sometimes
we do sometimes we don't. And so, this
is why we call that sometimes
there's a phenomenon that's called
implicit regularization or implicit
bias, right? Is that the algorithm that
we are going to use, right? The so in
maybe for maybe the gradient descent
algorithm or the two the choice that we
make in the hyperparameter of the
gradient descent algorithm is going to
indirectly define this notion of
complexity. Right? But for now, for this
lecture, we just think about this as
someone is giving us someone is giving
us this complexity, right? We are just
going to use it
theoretically, right? As as a tool to
understand when an algorithm works.
Any questions so far?
Or
Good. So, we have covered the data
distribution, we have covered the model.
Let me just mention very briefly what
about the error metric. Okay? So, the
error metric, just again,
um
think for example
uh
thinking in the simplest case of a
regression, like squared squared loss.
Um so, given some measure No, like for
example, if you give me this point was
lost, like a a way to compare two
different levels, for example, just the
the you know the the square difference,
we can now take this function and cons-
and build it and upgrade it, transform
it into a function that assigns the
risk, like the loss of a of a particular
hypothesis, right? And so, the first
notion of uh
of error, like the the notion of the
notion of loss, is what is the what is
the loss that is that's happens on
average, right? With respect to the my
data distribution.
Right? So, this is what we call the the
population loss or like the test error.
Okay? So, given a hypothesis F,
R of F is telling us, if we just read
through this equation, is telling us on
average with respect to the data, like
the the expectation with respect to the
data, this is this expectation, what is
the agreement between the true function
and the function that my model has
produced, right? This is F.
Okay? So, this is an object that is
completely deterministic, right? There's
a you know, it's a there's no randomness
here, but of course it's an object it's
a quantity that we cannot measure,
right? Because in general, we do not
have access to the to this object. We
don't have access to the population
distribution, and of course we don't
have access to the function that we are
trying to learn, right? Otherwise, there
would be no point in trying to solve the
problem.
So, we resort to a kind of an empirical
version of this loss, which is the
empirical loss or also of course the
training error.
Training error, training loss. Okay? I
guess all of these things, I guess you
are familiar with them, but uh
just to so that we can agree on the
language, right? So, this is a
the it's a function that is random,
right? In that case, this is a random
function.
Right? And this is deterministic.
Okay? So, the random this random
function is an average over the data the
the the the available data the observed
data points of the basically it's the
just replacing the expectation by the
empirical expectation.
Okay?
And so, you might ask, "Okay, what is
the How are these two functions related
to each other?"
Well, they have an obvious relationship,
right? Is that for any fixed hypothesis,
if I think about the now
what if I fix the func- the function F,
right? Uh I have here a number, so this
is a number, right? And this is a random
variable.
Right?
And so, uh it's easy to to see that if
you look at the expectation of this
random variable, right? So, the
expectation of R hat
is precisely R.
Right? Because if I if I take a you
know, uh
you know, this is an average
of random variables that are independent
IID, and each of them its expectation is
by definition R R of F.
All right?
So, we can compute easily for a fixed
hypothesis F, we can easily compute the
first moment, which is the function that
we care about, and the second moment,
right? So, what it means is that if we
think now if I try to to visualize this
loss functions, right? Maybe I have this
function R that does something like
this,
right? And so, now the the the so, this
would be the test error. Now, if I think
about the training error, well, if I fix
any point, so this is my space of
functions, right? So, this is space
space of F. So, if I fix any function
here, well, this looks like a random
variable that is has expectation here,
right? So, maybe at every point I have
some uh
you know, some kind of like notion of
function that the in the training set
does something like this.
Okay? Obviously, this is a illustration,
right? That doesn't um
doesn't do justice, right? I mean, this
is just a thing that I I did as a
sketch.
But
um
the problem Well, the question is
uh
you know, uh we would
obviously the function the thing that we
care about in in practice in machine
learning is to find a F such that the
test error the population loss is small.
That's obviously what we want, right? We
want to try to get as close as possible
from F star.
The problem of course is that we can
only access the the only proxy that we
can use uh is the empirical loss, right?
So, the intuition here is that the
closer these two functions are to each
other, the better my chances are of
solving the problem, right? It's like
this is really I'm just repeating a you
know, the
obviously the intuition that you all
have that if I have an algorithm that
makes that minimizes the training error,
you expect the test error to also be
minimized.
Okay?
And for this is important if I want to
quantify
if I want to try to give some
guarantees, to understand, okay, but how
far are these two functions?
So, here, if I fix a point, right? For
any fixed point, I can you know, the by
just applying basic
uh statistics, right? The fact that this
this this is an average here of
independent and independent random
variables, I know that the variance,
right? Is of the order one over n,
right? Because uh if I look at the
variance of an average of n IID random
variables, as you know, the standard
deviations is divided by one over square
root of n, right? Like the squared like
the variance the second moment is of the
is divided by n.
But here there's a little problem,
right? And I I probably
you know, some of you might have already
spotted, right? That here I'm I'm doing
a very kind of I'm I'm I'm trying to do
like a shortcut, right? I'm I'm trying
to to pretend that the problem is very
easy. I'm computing the variance when I
fix the function F, right? When I fix
the hypothesis.
So, if if of these these arguments about
uh you know, computing these these
fluctuations of these functions, right?
They
the same the the underlying assumption,
right? Is that the function F is chosen
independent of the data, right? You just
fix the data fix the function F and look
at what the fluctuations like this.
Of course, the algorithm, right? The I
mean, in in our in practice, we don't
want to do that, right? In practice,
we
we want to adjust the function F
depending on the data.
Okay? So, we are not interested I mean,
what we need is not understanding what
is the fluctuation that I have for a
fixed hypothesis, we want something
stronger. We want to be able to control
the difference between these two
functions
essentially for any choice of F that we
can make that we can possibly make.
And this is what's called a uniform
bound, right? Instead of having a
pointwise bound that basically just
looking at the basically the variance of
a random variable, I need to compute
what is the worst fluctuation, right?
What is the what is the worst deviation
between R and R hat over a certain
classes of hypotheses, right? This is
what's called a uniform bound.
And probably you have
is one such class of uniform
concentration.
All right, this is the error metric.
Okay.
So, now we are we can now discuss about
the algorithm. And again, here for
algorithm, it's kind of a algorithm
taken in the theoretical sense, right?
It's kind of a meta algorithm. It's kind
of a a principle, right? So, what what
is what is the principle for learning
uh in the case of supervised learning?
Well, as I said, our goal is to minimize
the risk,
but we only have access to the kind of
the the
kind of a random like a an approximation
of R that is random, right? That is this
training loss.
So, in order to succeed and to have this
hope that optimizing the training error
is going to get us something close to
the test error, to minimize the test
error, we need to have some control. We
need to instead of trying to look at
these fluctuations uniformly over over
all possible hypotheses, we can say that
we we need to consider a ball.
Right? We need to use in a sense in a
sense like a like a notion of like a
limited set of hypotheses.
And here for this, how do we construct
how do we limit the size of the
hypothesis set? Well, we just use the
notion of complexity that I described
before, right?
So, we are going to focus our attention
to the hypotheses in our class, right?
So, we are going to look at the
hypotheses in our class, but only those
that have small complexity, right? So,
we have one hyperparameter here that is
delta, right? That is kind of the radius
of
uh you know, this like large space of
hypotheses, it would be the the you
know, the the maximum size
uh of like the complexity set, right?
So, in the case of neural networks, for
example, you could say, well, I'm only
going to try to look for neural networks
whose, you know, whose norm like where
the norm of the parameters is not larger
than, let's say, 1,000. Right? That
would be an example of controlling the
size of the of your set. Right? And then
by by choosing the maximum allowed norm,
you are you can make your hypothesis
class smaller or bigger.
Okay?
And so, once this is established, now
there's a very natural algorithm, right?
Which is, well,
I'm going to consider an estimator,
right? F hat
of delta,
which is, well, amongst all the
hypotheses that have small complexity,
I'm going to choose the one that has the
smallest training error.
Right? That's what's called empirical
risk minimization.
Right? I hope that this is an intuitive
algorithm. Right? It's essentially the
algorithm that any reasonable person
would choose. Right? It's like, okay,
uh I'm going to I don't want to have I
don't want to have to deal with
potentially very, very large fluctuation
between train and train and test, so I'm
going to just look for small like a like
a reduced set of hypotheses, and amongst
those, I want to, of course, choose the
one that best fits the data.
Okay? Because here, remember, we are
making this assumption that there's no
noise. I mean, the data here, the labels
are completely clean.
And so, this problem I I stated to you
in what we call the constrained form,
right? Because we are trying to solve a
constrained optimization problem. Right?
The constraint is that our family of a
function F is in this ball.
Or
as you know,
uh constrained optimization is a kind of
a
close cousin of uh penalized like I we
can we can transform constrained
optimization problems to unconstrained
optimization problems through what's
called the Lagrange multipliers. Right?
And so, we can introduce a penalty here,
right? Or like a regularization, if you
want,
where we add the complexity into the
loss. Right? So, now our new test
objective is the the empirical loss that
we had before plus a regularization
term.
Okay?
And so, before in this problem,
we had this hyper we had a single
hyperparameter, which is delta. Right?
It's a scalar.
And here now we have another
hyperparameter that is lambda, right?
Which is the size of the the strength of
the regularization. And these two
parameters are in correspondence. Right?
So, so
in one-to-one correspondence.
There's another uh naturally related uh
regime of uh ERM, which is what we call
the interpolation form.
Okay? And this is a uh popular in you
know, in neural networks, uh
in in particular in the regime where
they have a lot of parameters. And this
is really the problem this is really the
the regime say, okay, I'm going to
if I have a neural network that has a
lot of parameters, maybe I have enough
capacity, right? I have enough
expressivity to ex-
plain all the data that you're getting.
Right? I can fit all the data points.
So, and maybe and you might you might
you might see you might argue that,
okay, but there's not a single neural
network that can explain the data,
there's many, many possible choices of
parameters that explains the data.
Right? Like this is the classical
example where um
let's say,
here in 1D, let's I have a bunch of
points, right? This is my points, let's
say.
And imagine that your hypothesis class
is polynomials.
Okay?
Just to say something. So, maybe there's
this,
you know, this function explains the
data, right? And this function
also explains the data. Right? This is
the the classical
example that everyone shows. Right?
So, amongst all the polynomials that
that pass through the points, what does
this ERM tell us? You have to choose the
one that has smaller complexity. For
example, here would be the one that has
smallest degree.
Okay?
I mean, this to me looks like a
reasonable algorithm. I don't know if if
for you also it's the same. Right? For
me, this is makes a lot of sense.
All right.
So, what can we say about this
algorithm? I mean, is there
uh how do we argue how do we uh start,
analyzing the behavior, like the
properties of this
uh ERM?
Okay.
So, let's do it.
So, first we consider an arbitrary uh
hypothesis class, right? So, this is all
very, very abstract and very general,
where uh and I'm considering the ERM
like this empirical risk minimization uh
using a ball. And I'm just using the
constrained form for simplicity. All
right? So, I have a I have chosen some
amount of some some, you know,
size of the complexity, and I find the
solution, the hypothesis that is in that
set.
Okay?
So, now I want to compare I want to see
how good is this hypothesis. Right? So,
how good is this hypothesis in terms of
what I care about, which is the the
risk, the the true risk, like the test
error.
So, what I can do is I can compare it
with the baseline. Right? So, and given,
you know, our choice, let's do it with
the best of the best. Right? So, here
I'm saying, okay, if you were God,
right? And you were given this function
R, and you could really look for all all
all the possible hypotheses in the world
that were in your, you know, in your
universe,
right? What is how worse do you do
versus this kind of omnipotent learner?
Well, so the first thing that we can do,
right? Is that
we Now, the goal is really to try to
understand this error. Right? Like to to
try to break this this error into things
that we can interpret and that we can
analyze.
So, first is that
um
the first thing to observe, right? Is
that this hypothesis F hat
it it depends it it involves a certain
delta, right? It depends on this
quantity number.
Right? So, what first we would like to
do is to exhibit this parameter that is
important in our problem.
Right? This delta.
So, the natural thing that we can do is
instead of looking at the infimum over
all the possible class F, we can add and
subtract the infimum over all the
hypotheses, but now restricted to have
complexity delta.
Right? That's
that's the first step that we did here.
Right? So, what we have said, like the
in this step, we have just added and
subtracted this term. Right? So, the
equality is legit.
Okay? So, now I can think about this
this uh
regret, if you want, or this like this
gap
as the sum of two terms, right?
Um
And two terms The two terms are
non-negative.
Right? So, here we have a term that is
the difference between
the best I could do
uh you know, unconditionally,
uh with the best I could do when I
restrict the complexity to be delta.
Right? That's the green that's the red
term.
And then I have the other one, which is
the difference within population between
my hypothesis F and the best hypothesis
I could I could have taken a posteriori
if I had access to the population
distribution. Right? To the to the true
function R.
All right?
Okay, but this is still, of course, uh
something that I cannot, you know, the
the the
it still is a a little bit
you know, the the first term is
something that we we don't really
understand. So, let's try to decompose.
So, there's another thing that, of
course, uh involves F hat. Right? So,
remember that F hat
is something that I have obtained by
looking at the by looking at the at the
empirical All right. So, now let's do
one As I was saying, for the for the
algorithm, right? Remember that the
algorithm is only looking at the
empirical at the training loss. Right?
So, maybe we want to think about how we
can now,
you know, introduce the training
objective in this equation.
So, we can do just do exactly the same
trick as before, we can add and subtract
terms that depend on the empirical loss.
Right? So, that would be the next. Okay?
So, now we are, you know, instead of
using R, we we use R hat. And of course,
every time I do a change, I need to make
sure that I, you know, that I remove it.
Right? So, here I added
and here I I subtracted.
Here I added this new term,
and here I, you know, I I put it again
with a with a different with the
opposite sign. Right? So, this is this
is still true.
Right? And so, now we have something
quite interesting, because now we have
something that we can analyze. Right?
What is this green term?
So, the green term is measuring what? Is
measuring what is the training error of
my of my hypothesis of my F hat
minus
uh hypothesis like the, you know, like
the the minimizer of the training loss.
Now, this is R hat here, right? So, here
we have R hat over the the, you know,
the the hypothesis space restricted to
have uh
ball delta.
So, if you remember from the previous
slide, right? How we how did we define
the ERM? Right? So, if we if we had used
if we could use the actual solution of
the ERM, this term would be what?
This term would be
Just if you remember the ERM, right? The
ERM is saying, okay, I'm going to choose
a hypothesis, the solution that
minimizes the empirical loss over the
ball."
So, this is exactly what you have here,
right? So, this thing would be zero,
right? If we were using
the ERM, right?
All right.
So, the the red term here is exactly the
term that we have here, right? So, these
are This is just definition. And now we
have
basically the price that we pay, like
the you know, the the fluctuation,
right? Between the training error and
the test error. Sorry, between the Yeah,
between the the training loss and the
population. Right? So, we have a
difference between R of F hat and R hat
of F hat.
And here we have the difference between
the two infimums.
And so,
we can now control these fluctuations,
right? We can just uh um
because now everything is measured
in the ball, right? We can upper bound
the sum of these two terms
by just two times the largest possible
fluctuation between the two functions.
All right?
And so,
now we have something where we have
really,
you know, isolated or identified the
sources of error, right? Because really
now this is a term
that we call
the blue term, is what we call the
statistical error, right? So, the
statistical error
is the term that depends
on how good is our proxy, right? So, how
you know, how close is the training loss
to the to the test loss in the sense of
in the uniform sense, right? The we
measure the how how close are these two
functions with a uniform ball,
and then we have an error that depends
on how good
our hypothesis space approximates the
true function.
And then we have another another error,
like that is the green one, which
measures how good we are at optimizing
at solving the optimization problem.
Okay, which is something that measures
how good, you know, how
how much So, what is the difference
between
the empirical loss of our function and
the best empirical loss in our in our
set.
Okay, that's it.
Um is it clear? Is this the composition
of error clear?
Okay, like the the punchline here is
that when we analyze the you know, the
the generalization error, like the
performance of a machine learning
algorithm, the error that we make
is always a combination of the three
errors, right? There's one that comes
from the amount from the approximation
side, like the expressivity of the
model.
There's another one that comes from the
statistics, which is again something
that you can control with its uniform
fluctuations. And then there's another
source of error that comes from the
optimization side.
Right?
Okay, I can also We can now, you know,
just uh make sure that we understand by
having a little diagram, little picture.
Okay, that's something that I myself I I
like sometimes to just be view things.
So, here's a you know, here's a
function, right? It's the loss. So,
these circles, you think about these as
some kind of level sets of a function,
right? Like of this loss.
And so, here in the bottom of this uh
landscape, this is the F star, which is
the best, right? Like the function that
minimizes the population error. All
right, it's like the best of the best.
So, this function, the blue function, we
don't know, right? It's a it's a
unknown.
So, what we have is another function,
that the one that the algorithm sees,
which is the empirical loss, like the
training loss.
So, I told you that these two functions
are, you know, are supposed to be close
to each other, but they're not the same,
right? And here in for these purposes of
illustration, I just put them, you know,
like the level sets are different,
right?
So, instead of looking at this landscape
in the overall space, remember that we
said is that we just look at this
landscape in a ball,
right? That's what the algorithm is
going to is just going to focus all its
efforts in a subset of functions, right?
Which are these ball, right? This
hypothesis class.
And so, now we are what we're going to
do is what is what does the algorithm
do? Okay, so the algorithm in the ERM,
we are going to say, "Okay, in the in
the yellow ball, I want to find a
function
whose
you know, whose empirical loss is the
lowest possible."
Okay, so naturally, what we do is we
pick this point, right? Which is kind of
like
laying at the at the level set, like the
the you know, the smallest level set
that is touching the yellow ball.
Okay, this one here.
Um so, I was just uh
trying to illustrate um
kind of ju- you know, visually
uh this decomposition of error. Let me
just maybe for the sake of a refreshing
you know where we started.
So, that's the population error, right?
That's the kind of the the true the true
game, right? Of trying to get as close
as we can from the bottom of this well.
Um we are going to the only way we have
it is to go, you know, to go downhill in
the following the kind of the the
magenta level set, right? Which are kind
of the the training loss.
And we are only going to, you know,
because we can only control the
fluctuation between the train error and
the test error over a kind of a small
size of hypothesis,
we can just restrict our attention to
what happens in the blue in the blue
ball. And so, in the blue ball, the you
know, our best estimator is going to be
here, right? Just at the intersection,
right? Of the of the ball of the ball
with the with the level set of smallest
loss, right? For the training.
And so, uh we would like to to
understand how far, right? Is the risk
between these two functions between
these two points. Okay?
And so, the decomposition of error, what
it tries to do is to to express, to
break, to to control this error, to
upper bound this error with basically
two sources of error, right? Like just
assuming that here we have been able to
optimize the ERM, right? It's just
breaking it into terms, right? And the
two terms visually
are now easy to see because they depend
on this green point, which is what would
be the best test error
uh
in your uh ball, right? And so, you
know, as you can see, now if you change
the size of this ball, right? There's
there will be one
error that is going to become bigger,
right? And one error that is going to
become smaller, right? And obviously, if
I increase the radius of the ball, the
approximation error is going to
decrease, right? Because you know, I'm
going to get closer and closer to the
star,
but of course, I need to compute
fluctuations over a set that is bigger
and bigger, right? So, the fluctuations
are going to increase. The statistical
error might increase.
On the other hand, of course, if the
ball becomes shrinks and shrinks, the
approximation error will grow and the
statistical error will uh
uh will decrease.
I guess this is like intuitive at this
point.
All right. So,
the the the bo- the bottom line here is
that when now we think about problems in
high dimensions, right? Where the input
space has a lot of is is very large,
like for example, images or you know,
very complicated data,
it's actually quite it's actually a big
challenge to control all the errors at
the same time, right? And this is what
what I called kind of what we call here
the challenge of high-dimensional
learning. Okay?
And so,
um
in the
in uh in high dimensions,
uh in the first challenge is how can we
control this approximation error, right?
So, we need to for example, think about
constructing spaces of hypotheses that
have a lot of expressivity, right? That
can approximate
complicated functions that live in high
dimensions, right? And that's
not easy, right? That's We're going to
see that that's not easy.
The statistical error, right? Like doing
the I mean, controlling the
approximation error alone
in the is easy, right? Sorry, uh so,
approximating like making either of
these errors small is easy.
What is hard is making all the errors
small at the same time.
Okay?
Um
So, the statistical error, as I said,
it's something that
we can control using basically the using
the theory of uh uniform fluctuation,
right? These concentration bounds that
really uh
uh give us a very tight result that are
non-asymptotic, right? That really work
for any size of the training set.
And finally,
uh the optimization error, right? Is
something that we also need to We cannot
forget, right? The the there can be
situations where we have a good
theoretical understanding on how to make
the blue error and the red error small,
but we have no algorithm to find the
solution, right? Then in that sense, we
have a bound that is kind of useless,
right? Because we it doesn't explain the
reality, right? It's not something that
we can we can execute efficiently with a
computer,
right? So, it's all the challenge is
really about how can we make uh how can
we understand
at the same time, simultaneously, how to
make these errors small at the same
time.
Okay, that's the challenge of
high-dimensional learning.
And this challenge is by, you know, by
all measures, still open, right? There's
there's really no closed theory
for how to do that with neural networks.
Okay?
Good.
And so, why is the why is this problem
hard in high dimensions?
Uh
well, the reason, or like one of the
sources of like diagnostic for why is
this hard, is really not something new,
right? It's not specific to neural
networks.
In fact, there's many situ- in many
situations in science when we increase
the size of the input of the problem,
things might kind of fail, like it might
you know like blow up, right? And and
and this is really coined, you know,
very naturally very very
you know, famously by Bellman in what he
what he called the curse of
dimensionality, right? In his context it
was in the context of dynamic
programming, right? Like some algorithms
have like with dimension.
But this phenomenon now is very
pervasive, right? It's pervasive in in
statistics, in optimization, in
approximation, right? In all the areas
in particular that are connected with
machine learning.
And so
maybe one and one way to to motivate and
to illustrate this principle, like this
curse of dimensionality is really to
relate back to like you know basic
principle for learning, right? Which is
something that I think we we can all
relate. Right? So the
basic idea like of why you know a
machine learning would succeed, like why
on earth if I know the value of the
function at certain points I will be
able to know know the value of the
function everywhere else.
It really it's really sitting on the
property, right? Like look at these
pictures, right? I mean you you you see
here there's a you know, there's a
orange dots and gray dots, right? We can
all try to we can all figure out infer
that maybe there's a line, right? I know
these dots are really generated by
something that you know, passes through
these points. Right? And here the same
thing, right? Maybe we would not all
have drawn the same curve exactly, but
something that basically essentially is
the same object, right?
And the reason why we are able to do
that reliably and without much you know,
you know, without being too worried
about oh whether my model will
generalize or not
is because it's really the proximity,
right? We are you know, like the
empirical density, right? The
the sampling the sampling of the dots is
not too far, right? From basically if I
know the value of the function at these
points, I can extend it naturally by no
by notion of proximity, right? Any point
that is sufficiently close to my point,
right? My training point, I can just
propagate the value of the function,
right? So this is really a kind of one
of the cornerstones of machine learning
methods, right? Most like you know, that
use classical idea, right? This is like
kind of a local methods like nearest
neighbor or kernel methods, right?
They're all based on these notions of
similarity.
So the problem of course is that what
happens with this principle as we go to
higher high dimension, right? If I start
to give you these points instead of in
dimension two in dimension 200, right?
Can we still argue the same way?
Well, that's the problem, right? That's
that's the and this is you know, like
the the way this
example works, right? Is that the only
assumption that makes these curves work,
right? It's really like that the
function that I'm trying to learn is a
little bit continuous, right? Has a
little bit of smoothness, right? So that
every point if I know the value of the
function at one point, I can kind of
inter- like extend it around in the
neighborhood of the training points.
So this is formalized by the by a notion
of Lipschitzness, right? Like I want to
say that my function is Lipschitz.
What I'm saying is that if I if I want
to know the value of the function at
that certain point X
and I know the value of the function at
a certain point X prime
right? To the extent that X and X prime
are close
you know, I can extend the function,
right? Like I you know, approximating
the value of the function, you know,
I can you know, if if the if the X and X
prime are close f of X is close to f of
X prime, right? Which is a like a very
natural notion of smoothness.
Okay, so this is really a a pretty uh
pretty natural assumption, right? That
many many functions that you want to
learn in life have this property, right?
Is that you change the input a little
bit, the output changes a little bit.
Right?
The question is can you learn functions
in that class, right? In all generality,
right? If you know, if we could just
have an algorithm that would learn in
that class, right?
Kind of we would be essentially solving
machine learning, right? Because this is
a very very general assumption.
Okay? So so to formalize it, let's
assume that my target is a function that
is one Lipschitz
and I the data point like the input is
drawn from let's say Gaussian
distribution, right? In dimension
And so the formula the question I'm that
we are asking
is
how many samples do you think are needed
if you want to estimate this function up
to error epsilon, right? So I would like
to predict this hypothesis, right? So I
have a function I have a input of the
problem would be X I and then F star of
X I
for a number of samples.
Okay, so this this I pass it through
some algorithm
that produces some hypothesis F hat
and what I want
is that the expectation over this
Gaussian data, right?
of F
of X
minus F star of X
is
smaller
up to a constant and epsilon.
Right?
So that's what we want.
All right.
So
um
what do you think?
So here the parameters of the problem,
right? There's there's basically there's
two parameters of the problem, right?
There's the dimension D
right? This is the input dimension.
There's the error epsilon.
So this is this is the target error.
And there's a number of data points.
So the question really is how the how do
these three parameters how are they
related to each other?
Right? And what do you think?
Okay, so this is a
um
I was going to put this as an exercise,
right? So
perhaps what I can do is just give you
like a little little like a little hint,
right? And I will leave the you know,
the rest of the of the argument for
yourself, right? If you want to think
about it think about it about this
problem just to make sure that you know,
the the concepts that we have been
discussing so far are well understood.
Okay, so the question really is that we
want to understand you know, N
how should N depend
N depends
on epsilon and D.
Okay?
So for the upper bound for the upper
bound what I mean is that okay, let's
first try to give an algorithm, right?
Like a like a estimator
that
and let's try to you know, to give a
like a to give a number of samples like
that is even if it's very large that
will certify that we can in fact learn
this thing sufficiently.
Okay, so what is a natural algorithm
for um
learning Lipschitz functions?
Okay, so here
maybe I can just give you kind of a as a
hint, right? So let's assume that we
have these points, right? That are our
training points
are drawn from this Gaussian
distribution in dimension D.
Right? So we know the value of the
function at the points that I draw here.
Right?
And now
I think I can change the color here.
Doesn't matter.
And now I have a new point, right? That
is solid.
Let's say here, right?
So here I know X1, these are my training
sets
and here I have a new point X
and I want to predict f of X.
Okay, so
what is my estimator?
Right? What is my my what is the best
function
that I can use to analyze, right? So
what I know, right? Is that my target is
Lipschitz one.
Okay?
So
what I can what I can first do is that
well I know by I I know that uh
you know, like trying to recap from
before I need to think about complexity,
right? I
I need to think about the Lipschitz
class also defining certain complexity.
Here if you go back to the definition,
right? What do you think is a reasonable
notion of complexity for Lipschitz
function?
Someone I don't know if someone wants
can answer.
Class?
Okay, I don't see you guys, but um
well
I assume that uh
that you heard the question. So I think
perhaps a natural notion of complexity
for Lipschitz functions is this guy
here, this constant here, right? If beta
is very small
it means that the function maybe you
know, cannot change even less, right? So
like the Lipschitz constant, right? Is a
is a is in fact a natural notion of
complexity for Lipschitz functions. In
fact
not quite exactly, but but essentially
it's a norm, right? So you can you can
essentially think about the Lipschitz
constant as being the norm of the
function. Right? You need to you know,
to you need to add some some kind of
like supremum of the function, but
anyway, for us it's going to be good
enough.
Right? So, I could say I I could just
think about this.
I could define my estimator
as the argmin
right?
The argmin of the Lipschitz constant
such that
f of xi
equals to f star of xi.
Right? For all i.
So, here what I'm saying is that I'm Hi
John, sorry for interrupting you.
Yeah. Uh maybe because the class is not
familiar with the Lipschitz function
because they didn't take like
optimization class yet. So, maybe if you
could briefly talk about the Lipschitz
function definition.
Right. Right. So, here's the Okay, so
here's the definition of a Lipschitz
function. Right? So, a Lipschitz
function, right? Is a function such that
if I
uh change the input a little bit, right?
In the sense that the x minus x prime is
small,
then I can use this distance between the
points in the input to bound the
distance of the function values. Okay?
So, let's try to think about an example
of a function that is Lipschitz and then
an example of a function that is not
Lipschitz. Right? Just to make sure that
we understand. Right? So, like a
function of a Lipschitz function, right?
So, for example, if I think about um
Okay, just look at an example, f of x
cosine
of uh let's say omega times x. Right?
So, do you think that this function has
the Lipschitz property?
In the sense that if I if x and x prime
are very close,
do f of x f of x and f of x prime are
also very close. Right? So, we can just
look at this. Right? f of x
minus f of x prime.
Okay, what do we think?
We can apply We can do something, right?
Here we can use
uh I guess you have taken calculus,
right? So, so we can use the fundamental
theorem of calculus.
Right? So, we can just think about this
as the integral
from x to x prime
of the derivative of f.
f prime of t dt.
Yeah?
And now we can put the absolute value
inside.
So, it's the integral between x and x
prime
of the absolute value of f prime of t
dt.
But now what is what is the absolute
value
of So, what is the derivative of f of x?
Right? So, we know that f prime of
x
is just the omega minus omega sine of
omega x. Right?
So, what we have here is that this is
actually uh
controlled by omega, right?
times
uh the absolute value of sine. The
absolute value of sine is always smaller
than smaller or equal than one. Right?
So, this is just equal
This is just uh controlled by this times
x minus x prime.
Okay?
So, this is an example of a function
whose Lipschitz constant now is
precisely this omega.
Is it clear?
This is an This is just uh Here of
course I'm I'm using um
you know
maybe
another way to think about it, right? Is
that if I have a function
whose uh derivative is bounded
everywhere,
the the bound of the derivative is
actually a bound on the Lipschitz
constant.
Okay?
Uh an example of a function that is not
Lipschitz.
Let's try to give an example of a
function that is not Lipschitz.
Well, that's not should not hard because
I can just think about like a function
like like a step function.
Okay?
So, you think about the step function,
obviously this is not Lipschitz not
Lipschitz, right? Because if I zoom in
in what happens in in this
discontinuity,
you know, I can I can choose x and x
prime that are very very very close,
right? One is in one side of the
discontinuity, the other one is in the
other side, and so f of x minus f of x
prime is always going to be one, right?
Even though so the the you know, the
left hand side is always one, and the
left and the right hand side I can make
it as small as I want. Right? So, that's
an example where it's a function that is
not Lipschitz.
Is it clear?
Well,
I hope it's clear.
Um
All right.
So, now I go back to our example, right?
So, we want to
uh
So, we we want to we define this
estimator, which is the function that
has the smallest possible Lipschitz
constant that fits the data.
Okay?
And so,
now we would like to understand
uh So, then the question for you, right?
Is to
uh compute or like to have a sense of
what is this error?
Right? So, is this function any good
to approximate
what I want. Right? So, um
I will um
uh let you think about it and uh
tomorrow or you know, we can of course
uh iterate on these um
uh
on this question uh just to see uh how
are you how are you
So, to see where where you are all
right. Right? But the point is that here
we are trying to define them.
Uh we are just we don't care about the
So, here we are interested in the upper
bound. Right? So, we are just uh trying
to build an algorithm that is going to
guarantee to succeed provided that n,
the number of training points, is
sufficiently large. Right? And we are
just going to give
some upper bound on the number of n for
which this is works this works.
But once you have found this result,
you might ask a question, okay,
uh but is the number of data points that
I found here uh
the best I can do. Right? So, so do I
need as many data points? Maybe I maybe
I haven't been smart enough, and maybe I
could have found a better algorithm,
right? A better solution than this one
that would have worked with smaller
number of points.
That's the lower bound.
And here I'm going to also give you a a
hint, right? On on on on how to think
about the lower bound.
Uh and I will also let you develop it.
Right? And let's let's try to think
about this
right?
So, here what we are going to do
is that we are going to build
a target function, okay? One specific
target function
that is going to be Lipschitz
and where I claim that unless you have a
number of data points that is
exponentially large in dimension,
you cannot learn.
Okay?
So, here's the idea.
The idea is that I'm going to take my
inputs.
Think about the input space. So, this is
the space in dimension d. Right? So,
this is Rd.
So, think about Rd, right? And now think
about all the possible
orthants of the d-dimensional Euclidean
space. Right? So, basically what I have
is I can think about all the points
of the form
um
Think about all the points of the form
z1 to zd
with zi that are
plus or minus one.
Okay?
So, basically these are the kind of the
corners
of um
kind of a hypercube. Right? So, um
Okay, so in dimension three, that I'm
drawing here, I have eight corners.
But of course in dimension d,
how many corners do I have? Right? So,
this is the
Let's look at this. Let's call it hd.
Okay, so obviously the number of points
in this hypercube
is going to be
But you think about it, right? So, we
have you know, every coordinate is one
bit. It's two choices, right? So, I have
two times two times two times two d
times. So, I have two to the d
points.
Right?
And so,
for every one of these points,
right?
Uh now I'm going to build a function
that is going to be uh
basically a a linear combination of
bumps. Right? So, I'm going to build a
function f
star of x
that is going to be
a sum from all the points that are in
the in the hyperplane, right? So, in
this hypercube.
And I'm going to choose
some coefficient that is like I can I
call z
cg, right? That this is going to be
also plus or minus one
times a little bump
centered at the point.
So, some uh
I wish I could erase. Uh I don't know
how to erase with this.
Well,
uh let me just
Okay?
So,
uh what I'm drawing here is that I have
a I have a a little function, right?
That is kind of a bump, right?
But I can I can I can place
uh around each of the corners of this
hypercube
and I can choose the sign. Right? So,
maybe I maybe in in this point I put it
upwards, in this point I put it
downwards, in this point I put it
upwards. Right?
You see what I mean, right? So, I have a
basically a
kind of a spin system, right? So, I have
two to the D possible locations and for
every location I can just choose up or
down.
Okay?
So, what I can do is that you can build
so, fact
we can build
a star
such that
it is
Lipschitz one.
Okay?
So, here I have a target function that
has this this possible form.
Okay?
So, now that the question for you
is you need to show
that
to learn that in order
to learn F
such that
in expectation
for the data
F hat of X minus F star
of X
is let's say let's say that it's this
this needs to be smaller
than
1/2, right? So, if I if I just want to
make sure
that I do an error that is kind of a
fraction of the energy
we need
N to be bigger
than
some constant
times two to the
Okay?
That's the exercise. Maybe question or
just
Is the exercise clear? Right? So, here I
gave you
kind of I gave you the construction,
right? This is the class of functions
that are going to be like you know, like
a local bumps
and then every at every you know, at
every corner of this hypercube I can
choose the sign of the bump.
Right?
So, what I what I'm claiming is that
if I want to learn this function with
error that is non you know, that is a
small, I need to observe a number of
points that is exponential in dimension.
Right?
And again, if
happy to follow up on this question
after you have given some thought about
it.
Right?
Good.
Okay.
Now, let me also let me briefly
tell you
that this curse of dimensionality,
right? That here in in the previous
example, this curse kind of related the
number of points that we need to observe
of the function if we want to learn it.
Right? So, you kind of
it's a statistical curse, right? It's a
something that depends on how many
observations that we need.
The curse also manifests itself in
approximation, right? Like the
approximation error is also going to is
also going to be affected by the curse
of dimensionality.
And so,
an example like the the prime example of
this curse of dimensionality in
approximation already appears with
neural networks that are the simplest
ones, right? Which are neural networks
that have a single hidden layer.
Okay?
So, so then the neural network it
defines a function that is this sum over
the neurons and every neuron, right? As
as you see here, every neuron has some
input weights
has a bias
and then an output weight, right? That's
a neuron. You know, this neuron has
parameterized by this kind of three
three num three parameters and then the
the function is just the sum, right? For
all these
number of neurons in the in the hidden
layer
that produce the output.
So,
there's very different ways to measure
the complexity in this class.
One example would be well, the width,
right? This is the width of the network.
And the other one is
you know, like variants of these are
given for example by the path norm,
right? Which is
if you're familiar with that weight
decay, that's the same thing, right?
It's it's the weight decay
like the sum, you know, it's like the
sum of the norms, right? Of the weight
of the weights,
you know, parameterizing them properly.
It doesn't matter for now.
So, we know that the class of neural
networks, right? Even in this shallow
sense
if we make the width very very large,
right? If we make the the width as large
as as we want
in fact, we can approximate anything
with that.
Right?
This is what's
you know, captured by what's called
universal approximation theorem, right?
And these are
in a sense these are
old, right? Like these were developed in
the '80s and the '90s.
Okay?
And so, what the the way these theorems
go is as follows. It says, "Okay, if my
activation function wall is not a
polynomial
then if I have a
sufficiently large width, I can
approximate any continued function."
This again is one of these results
that
potentially are not mean I mean they are
not telling us anything about whether
our algorithm is going to work or not.
Right?
What we need to understand is again the
rates, right? So, how do how do the
parameters of the problem relate to each
other? In particular, when they involve
the dimension, right? So, how do the
parameters of the problem depend on the
dimension of the data?
And so,
when we look at the rates, the situation
again is is very bad, right?
Because what we see is that if we take
target functions that have a little bit
of regularity, let's say that my target
is a function that has Sobolev has S
derivatives.
Okay?
So, if the function has S derivatives
then the number of neurons I need to
approximate it well
is going to depend, right? Like the
error is going to depend basically of
something that is
um
the rate is going to decay very very
slowly here, right? Like the error is
going to grow is going to decay at the
width to the minus S over D.
Okay?
So, what does it mean?
It means
that if I want to make the error
twice as small
how much wider do I need to make my net?
Okay? So, if I want to reduce my error
by two
what do I need to So, basically here
what I'm saying is that epsilon, right?
Is M
to the minus S
over D.
Right?
So, if I want to if I invert this
equation, right? So, M
is of the order of
epsilon
to the minus
um
D over S.
Okay?
And so, what we see here, right?
Is that if I want to reduce my error by
two
I need to multiply the number I need to
to augment the width by a factor that is
two to the D over S.
Okay? So, the S
is the number of derivative of my
function.
Typically
you know, in in any practical
application, okay, S might be one, two,
three, four.
Right?
And D might be
I don't know, 1 million, 2 million.
Okay? So, D over S is very large, you
know, certainly larger than 100.
So, you can see that this is this is
completely cursed, right? If I want to
keep the same approximation error,
right? As I increase the size of the
input,
it's not going to work, right? I need to
grow my network needs to grow
exponentially, more than anything that
can scale, right? It cannot scale like
that.
Um
there's a certain maybe these are this
hypothesis of having S derivatives is
too you know, is too optimistic, right?
There's okay, maybe this space is very
hard to approximate. Indeed, there's a
there's a another regular notion of
regularity that is more tailored to the
shallow neural networks, which is called
the Barron class, right? And this is a
it's a it's a it's another notion of
regularity that
just to you know, I don't want to go
into the details, but rather than having
something that you know, looks at the
some kind of like L2 norm like
regularities of the function, this is
basically saying that the function
can only needs only to be smooth along
certain directions, right? Doesn't need
to be smooth in all directions of the
space.
So, indeed in that sense, now we have no
curse, right? So, like the approximating
these functions with shallow neural
networks is efficient, right? Like the
number of neurons I need does not depend
on dimension.
But of course, remember there's no free
lunch, right? That's the the first
slide, right? So, if I make
a hypothesis like a target space where
neural networks have no curse, it
basically means that it cannot
approximate more things, right? So, this
space in a sense is is a bit restricted.
Is a is a
is an assumption that is
you know, this space is not sufficiently
expressive in general, right? Like
shallow neural networks in general are
not sufficiently expressive, right? In
the sense in this sense, right? In the
sense that the that the the width that I
need to approximate it is going to be is
going to be sufficient is going to be in
general very large, exponentially large
in dimension.
All right?
Okay. I'm almost done.
We also want to discuss about
you know what what can go wrong
when dimension increases now in
optimization.
Okay, when we when we need to think of
just about the problem of optimizing a
function.
So if I give you this function here,
this landscape on the picture of the
law, right? And I ask you to find the
global minimum of this function.
Well, obviously
if you look at it like this,
there's no not obvious at all that
following the gradient is going to give
you anything good, right? Because
there's so many you know, there's so
many places where this thing could get
stuck, right? There's many many places
where there you know, where the gradient
where the law where the minima is bad
like a local minima are are
bad, so
in general if I want to if you want to
give me some guarantee that you can that
you have found a global optimum,
basically you need to look through all
the points, right? You need to what we
call grid the space. You need to
you know, give me the take the input
domain and discretize it somehow, right?
And try to visit all the points in this
discretization and then evaluate the
function in all these points and give me
the minimum, right?
So again,
this as you can see is not going to
scale very well because if I want to
grid a ball of dimension D,
right?
With a you know, with a spacing that is
you know, as small as I want, right?
How many points do I need?
Right? This is the same question that we
had before. Right? So we have a point in
the sphere, let's say.
And we want the spacing to be let's say
epsilon.
Right?
So the number of points I need to read
the domain, I mean you we can actually
do it better with a cube, right? So if
we we think about the cube or like a you
know, in dimension two, this is you
know, this is like a
this is one and the spacing is epsilon,
right? So here I need one over epsilon
squared
and in general I need epsilon to the
minus D, right? To cover right? So the
number of points I need is exponential
in dimension.
So this problem is very hard
in general.
But how can we overcome this curse of
optimization in optimization? Well, it's
because you know, maybe this example I
give you here in this picture
is a
is not a practical it's not the scenario
it's not the optimization landscape
that we encounter in practice, right?
Maybe what we encounter in practice is
this closer to this thing here, like a
kind of a landscape more like coming
from nature, right? And these
landscapes, well, as you can probably
see, right? If I just let something fall
down like water,
well, I mean water is going to you know,
eventually find itself down to the lake,
right? And that's you know, maybe you
can argue that there are not so many
lakes, right? In a sense, local descent
methods
for a for a much you know, for a wide
class of landscapes that even even
though they are non-convex like this
one,
they might still give you give us good
intuition, you know, it
it might they might give us a good
solution for many problems.
Right? And this is what we call the
problems that have no bad local minima,
right? So all the local minima are
global.
And in fact,
we know that gradient descent is
actually a very efficient algorithm for
this kind of landscapes, right? There's
this very you know, sharp result for you
know, developed through many many
authors like culminated culminated by
Shi Jin
and others that basically says that I
can find
a
basically a local like you know, I could
I could find a minimizer of a function,
right? Under certain smoothness
assumption, the number of iterations
that does not depend on dimension.
Okay, so the the key takeaway from this
slide, right?
Is that when I think about optimizing
certain classes of non-convex functions,
gradient descent has no dependency on
dimension, right? The same way that I
told you before that if I want to you
know, approximate functions in the
Barron space, the number of neurons does
not depend on dimension.
And the same way that you know, if I
want to like estimate certain classes of
functions that are very small, then I
also get I have no dependency on
dimension, right? So the
you know, like the punchline here is
that
for
you know, for many problems that we care
about in machine learning, there's no
dependent you know, like the
optimization side is
in this context, right? Of course the
this is this is a condition that is very
strong, right? It's
like the
not always easy to verify,
but when you have this property, right?
Then you can efficiently find minimizers
of functions even if you are in high
dimensions.
Okay, so like the summary as so far
is that we have seen that
you know, like making making the right
assumptions like hypotheses about the
target function is the key is the key,
right? So if I think if I try to learn
functions in the Lipschitz class,
this is just too large, right? This
example is like think about any function
in high dimensions that I'm just
assuming
to be regular like local smoothness.
That's too large in the sense that there
are too many of such functions,
right? There's no I will need too many
samples to learn functions in that
class.
If I assume more stuff, for example I
make assumptions that the function has
many derivatives or the function has
this like Barron property,
then these things are too small, right?
Like then the the thing that is kind of
bothering me is no longer the
statistical error, but is the
approximation error, right? Is this idea
that remember that we had these three
sources of error and if you manage to
make one sort of error small, well,
suddenly there's the other one that is
becoming becoming large, right? So
for Lipschitz class, there's one that
dominates, for Sobolev class, there's
the other one that dominates.
So of course that what the the point
that we need to define more adaptive
function spaces. We need to have some
alternative to these choices.
And how can we find this alternative?
And this is where
kind of the geometry of the problem,
like the geometry like and then the
whole you know, the whole course
enters, right? This is where this is
where where we kind of where we need
to you know, in a sense zoom in and try
to understand that we are not trying to
solve just a arbitrary generic problem
in high dimensions. The input space that
I told you, right? This is the space of
images, right? It's it's a high
dimensional space,
but in fact it's a high dimensional
space with a lot of structure.
Right? This every one of these images,
right? You can think about it as an
image as a point in RD where D is a
number of pixels which is very large,
but you can also think about an image,
right? As a signal. Right? So we know
that this every one of these images,
right?
Is itself a function
whose domain is no longer very high
dimensions, whose domain is the grid of
the two dimensional grid, right?
And so
the the whole point, right? Is that by
kind of opening the box like that, now
we can access to a fine grain to you
know, to a better like a more tailored
notion of approximation. We can build
new spaces of functions, right? That are
again spaces of functions that have the
same input, but they leverage the
structure, the physical structure,
right? That comes from the basically
from the problem, right? Like in this
physical structure, as we can see,
can come from many many different
sources, right? So this physical that
the domain in which the data lives like
the domain in which the signal is, so it
can be the two dimensional grid for
images, it could be maybe measurements,
you know, over some sphere, for example
or some like symmetric group if you
think about like you know, lidar or like
as people like doing self-driving cars,
it could be
you know, measurements that are that
live in a certain graph, right? Where we
have this permutation equivalence or it
could be data that is measured towards
these kind of geometric structures like
you know, like meshes or manifolds.
And so
the the takeaways I can basically
the motivation for the next lectures,
right? Is really the fact is really the
following, right? Is that what I
presented today is a kind of a
almost like a pessimistic view of
learning in high dimensions, right? What
what I showed what I tried to to
motivate, right? Is that learning in
high dimensions is a very tough problem
and there's no free lunch, right? Like
there's no you know, there's no hope
that you can
you know, that you can learn arbitrary
functions in high dimensions.
So it's all about coming up with the
right assumptions, right? Like the right
spaces of functions that are going to be
relevant for us.
So what turns out that the you know, the
the typical the the classical spaces
that come from mathematics or from you
know, intuition that comes from low
dimensions, say Sobolev or you know,
Lipschitz or you know, C infinity or
like C this this notions of regularity
that come from low dimensional
mathematics do not scale well, right?
They do not apply they they are not you
know, giving us
a satisfactory answer either because
they are too large like Lipschitz or
because they are not a not adapted,
right? They are capturing a regularity
that is not the one that we expect from
the data.
So what we need in a sense is to use the
structure the physical structure of the
data like the images are not just you
know, high dimensional points, but they
are signals in a two dimensional grid
etc.
We are going to use this physical
structure to define new regularity,
right? And so
in the new in the next lectures, we are
going to articulate this regularity,
right? And and we are going to hear
about invariants, for example we are we
are going to hear symmetries. We're
going to hear about scale.
And these are the kind of the the key
physical properties
that will allow us
to break the curse of dimensionality,
right? To to learn
even if the input has a lot of
dimensions in a way that is efficient,
sample efficient.